President day how grand of you to join
me i'm lisa foiles and on today's analog
we are celebrating the good life of
ruling an island nation hoping not to
get crushed by neighboring world
superpowers or flattened by some kind of
tornado yes I'm talking tropico 5 the
city building and management sim for PC
coming soon to 360 and ps4 if you've
already risen to power and are looking
to be a puppet master elsewhere then
here are three games like tropico 5
tropico publisher calypso knows how to
give gamers a good caribbean city
builder so here's another game from
their collection Port Royale three
pirates and merchants just like tropico
5 you'll be surrounded by sandy beaches
and palm trees but life might be more
exciting depending on the career path
you choose a traitor who must develop
the economy by managing trade routes to
buy and sell goods or you can be a
bounty hunting pirate fighter choose
adventurer and you'll be less concerned
with things like building schools and
hospitals and more so with completing
quests on the high seas that require you
to grow and manage your fleet and slay
dirty rotten pirates this introduces
real-time battles between ships that are
very arkady like tropico there are
always politics involved one year you
may choose to assist Spain and fighting
England and the next say screw it and go
buddy up to the Dutch you can play
online with friends to create
competitive trading networks which is
doable because this game is really easy
to pick up and play but like tropico
actually winning is anything but simple
what's better than being El Presidente
how about ruling the world with an iron
fist as a criminal mastermind be the
baddie in the world domination simulator
evil genius like the dungeon keeper
games that came before it evil genius is
a stylized RTS with the feel of a 60s
style spy movie your goal is to
establish a secret base on an island
while instructing your minions and
henchmen to help fight off the good guys
or agents and keeping those pesky island
tourists from discovering your lair if
you liked tropico for its wit and
tongue-in-cheek humor than evil genius
is definitely the game for you funny is
the theme your goals are called evil
intentions your quests or acts of in
me involve things like hey disrupt
bastille day by shrinking the Eiffel
Tower I mean why not these dastardly
deeds not only result in hilarious radio
broadcasts sort of like tropicals crazy
radio DJ they raise the heat and alert
other countries that you are bad agents
are then sent to your lair and you fight
them off by planting traps like saw
blades that emerge from the ground
interrogations are even more fun and
usually result in an agent's trip to the
brain washing machine or being spun
around violently in a big mixing bowl
it's good to be bad my third pics are
usually curveballs and this one is only
a suggestion for die-hard tropical fans
it's another game by Calypso called
omerta city of gangsters maybe this game
didn't have the mainstream success as
tropico 5 but a lot of the criticisms
were about aspects that as a tropical
van I didn't really care about this is a
super stylized game set in Atlantic City
in the Prohibition era after defining
your characters backstory with a few
questions at the beginning RPG style
your goal is to work your way up to
crime lord this is tropico skin on a
different game it looks and plays very
similarly but instead of a president
your reign must be underground maintain
relationships with speakeasies casinos
and Gun Runners play nice or threaten
them with Molotov cocktails just like
the Presidente you got to make some
deals under the table there's dirty
money and clean money and don't be
afraid to pay off the coppers what are
they gonna do keep evidence to use
against you oh right yeah they do that
so once your gang is strong enough you
must engage in a turn-based battle with
tommy guns and pistols to get it back
there's also a great story which is
uncommon for a city building sim yes
it's a bit slow paced but I personally
spent countless hours with this game so
I can't be the only tropical fan it
appeals to find it at a cheap price
throw on a fedora and just enjoy the
roaring 20s if nothing else it's a good
excuse to wear a fedora
let me know your favorite tropico ESCA
games in the comments tweet me at least
foils and I'll see you next week for
another analog